the Victorian era was characterized by
the generation of a substantive amount
of wealth and one could argue that part
of what was happening on the Victorian
Beauty front was the advertisement by
Aristocrats that they could tolerate
this encumbrance in the name of beauty
because they had the financial resources
to sustain it you know there's there's
an example of that biologically it would
be in principle would be the peacock's
tale which is extraordinarily beautiful
but also quite the encumbrance and
apparently part of what it signifies
especially if it's perfectly symmetrical
and well-formed and heavy is that the
male who sports that plumage has
sufficient health and resources to pull
that off without dying it's an
exuberance of display on the sexual
front